i hope everybody knows
what day it is today it was two weeks
and one day ago
that donald trump promised in two weeks
he would be signing a brand new health
care bill
into law it didn't happen
nothing else has been said about it and
it was yet again
one of these horrible horrible lies so
if you've been waiting for it
i hope you've not been holding your
breath because it doesn't seem like
we're going to get it we are expecting
a particularly erratic and wild trump
at the top of the hour this will be i we
can't even really call these coronavirus
press briefings anymore because there's
actually very little about coronavirus
actually discussed um other than trump
bragging about things that he really
shouldn't be bragging about unless he's
going to announce the new health care
bill today
um and of course it's 24 hours after um
when it was supposed to be signed into
law but nevertheless
nevertheless um one day late would be
better than never
right so we will see what happens with
that i have
so many things to go over with you
sadly i do have to tell you that we are
probably just hours if not a couple of
days from hitting 160
000 u.s deaths um so far today 339
deaths
still several hours of reporting to go
32 000 cases
at this point i don't even really
believe the case numbers uh
you know that on july 16th they started
to go
directly to trump's department of health
and human services instead of to the cdc
i don't know if these case numbers are
accurate and i don't even know if the
death numbers are accurate to be
perfectly frank
but even if they are lying we are still
going to hit 160 000 deaths very very
soon
donald trump has been extremely
triggered
earlier today by nevada
deciding that um everybody's going to
get an absentee ballot
and that's exactly the right thing to do
when you've got a raging hundred year
pandemic and you want to have a safe
election
you vote by mail we have the technology
we have the systems we have the postal
service so what is donald trump doing
he's calling it an illegal late night
coup
he is saying the post office could never
handle the traffic now the reality is
the post office can perfectly fine
handle the traffic
unless you kneecap the post office
donald trump recently selecting one of
his big donors louis de joy
to be postmaster general and that is
exactly exactly what he plans to do
new reporting uh democratic senator joe
manchin has received letters from postal
workers in west virginia
that it appears as though they are going
to start shutting down post offices
and we are expecting of course that they
are also going to limit overtime hours
what's the effect of limiting overtime
hours well
if you've uh you're a mail carrier
you've got to go out and deliver what
you've got
5 p.m hits and you're not done yet if
overtime is banned
you go back to the post office what you
couldn't get to
gets left for the following day next day
you show up you've got to pick up that
day's mail and what you didn't get to
the previous day
5 pm hits overtime is not allowed now
you've got leftovers from day one and
new leftovers from day two day three
comes
i think you understand the idea is force
the post office to not
work well donald trump highly triggered
by this
correct decision from nevada we're going
to be talking about
that on the program tomorrow um i also
will be discussing on the program
tomorrow
uh oh congressman james clyburn
said he believes that donald trump
is going to refuse to leave after losing
by arguing that there's some kind of
emergency let's listen to what he had to
say now this is different than delaying
the election this is a different
hypothesis have the election trump loses
and then he justifies somehow staying in
do you really think donald trump is
comparable to adolf hitler
starting off wildly by the way what i
said
started about two and a half maybe three
years ago after one of his state of the
that i feel very strongly that this
man has taken on a strong arm tactics
and i feel very strongly that she
is mussolini putin is hitler
i said that back then and i believe that
i believe very strongly
this guy never had any idea
about being one to peacefully
transfer of power i don't think he plans
to leave
the white house he doesn't plan to have
fair and
unfettered elections i believe that he
plans to install himself in some kind of
emergency way
to continue to hold on to office and
that's why the american people
had better wake up okay so
listen is it possible that donald trump
is going to try
something to avoid no longer being
president yeah
i mean he's floating delaying the
election he's kneecapping the post
office
he's trying to prevent vote by mail he's
trot
you know of course trump is going to do
that i
actually think that these types of
segments are not the best thing to be
doing
because it should be regarded
as so outrageous and authoritarian the
mere idea of trump staying in power
that when you start getting people to
comment on well
here's how it could be done or here's
how it might be done or whatever
you are actually fueling the idea that
this is a legitimate debate and then you
have people on board
well listen i mean that we can't have a
rigged election if the election is going
to be rigged we should be looking at
delaying it
we can't allow corporate media to do the
let's bring on two opinions about
whether we should delay the election or
whether donald trump should just stay in
power for a little while
it shouldn't be legitimized the way it
should be reported on is
this is the stuff that despots do
this is outrageous we have never delayed
a federal election in this country
and we have never had a president refuse
to leave and that's it
and and and i think that there's not
that much to gain by doing
this type of thing um
oh i think it looks like we have to ban
a few people yeah hold on a second let
me ban some people
usually it's twitch where the ban hammer
starts being dropped but i'm gonna
unfortunately today it's on twitch um
[Music]
okay all right we've dropped a few band
hammers there thank you so anyway i'm
gonna talk more about this tomorrow we
talked about the postal service by the
way if you're interested
in the postal service stuff there's a
procedure for how you close a post
office
and it's already too late if you're
actually looking to close post offices
before the election that doesn't mean
they can't
do some dirty tricks but this is a
document that we'll be looking at very
very powerfully tomorrow as well so
those are a few of the things that will
be on tomorrow's program
as we stand by for donald trump at the
top of the hour
expecting a wild and unhinged donald
trump
i do want to say thank you to loretta
mcjoy who's new member number one today
at joinedpakman.com
and michael ratzlaff is new member
number two today at joinedpakman.com
huge thank yous happening on twitch mini
crow has subscribed on twitch
and also potato has subscribed with
twitch prime
very much appreciate that we might soon
have a
hype train triggered super chats are
coming in like uh
high pressure water alex endicott says
david your thoughts on trump firing the
ceo of the tennessee valley authority
i i don't know anything about that so
i'm not prepared to comment
danny thompson says here's a few dollars
to keep on naming these press conference
live streams with click baity titles
five dollars for creativity thank you
yeah if you so here's the thing i love
audience participation
if you have other suggestions for future
trump and maggie nanny live streams
email them to me through my website
contact form
i at this point it's become a meme unto
itself to
editorialize um the the live stream
titles and i'm glad to
you guys are far more creative than i am
so i'd love to hear from it
sweaty irate trump speaks to press might
be a good idea that one coming from
youtube
zachary foster says david do you think
dr bricks is now dangerous with her
messaging
yes also how ironic it would be if the
white house defends her by saying people
are sexist
yeah i have clips from months ago
calling out dr burks
nick hunziker says do you guys eat mac
and cheese with a fork or a spoon
i eat mac and cheese with a fork now
here's the reality
i from a practical perspective you can
eat mac and cheese with a spoon and it's
no problem whatsoever
it feels like dessert the only entree
the only the the only what would we call
them
non-dessert i guess like what dishes the
only dish
non-dessert foods that i try to eat with
a spoon would be soups
okay and so merely for optics i eat mac
and cheese with a fork the only
exception would be
if it's such a um
saucy for lack of a better term mac and
cheese that it's almost like a pasta
soup
then you might see me pull out a spoon
but yes i abs i eat mac and cheese with
a fork
and i'm very very proud to say that
zachary foster says follow-up question
how do we effectively convince people
that trump has nothing to do with the
vaccine people saying i won't take a
trump vaccine
yeah um i've talked about that a lot and
i've
issued a number of uh statements on that
so i don't know that i want to get into
it too too much today
but we do need to be aware that if there
is a vaccine
that starts to be available whenever but
soon
um trump is going to try to take credit
for it and he'll try to take credit for
it today he'll try to take credit for
plasma remedivar
you know all of the stuff he's going to
try to take credit for marika
l says congratulations on 15 years i
wish i would have found the channel
sooner
okay beautiful point marika
august is the this august
now i mean well this month uh is the
15th anniversary of the david pakman
show now
those first years you know i was in
fourth grade
and my microphone technique was lacking
and we were just on like a little
community radio station but
i'm still counting it okay which means
that
this year it's either august 17th or
23rd
we hit our 15-year anniversary
and we are going to try to set the
single month
record for new website members so
it all counts it already starts counting
that's my goal
in the meantime by the way um thanks to
you guys so
last week we hit 900 000 youtube
subscribers
we're already at 910 000 and my goal was
to get there by election day
last week based on social blades
projections we were estimated to hit a
million subscribers
on january 9th thanks to people starting
to
absolutely destroy the subscribe button
we've moved it up what is that five plus
nine two weeks so we've already pushed
the estimate for hitting a million
subscribers into december
now scheduled to be the day after
christmas december 26th
uh let's keep it going my goal would be
that as joe biden is claiming victory
over donald trump on november 3rd
we are rolling over to 1 million youtube
subscribers
it would be amazing
sorry i froze there i was getting too
excited um so in any case if you're
watching on youtube please do hit that
subscribe button it's free we've already
moved the data by
in the last week we moved the data by
two weeks
if every week we move it up by two weeks
we're gonna do it that's the math of it
i hired a math major to help me
understand that but that is the case
and that is how it will go um thanks to
the bad wolf
dirt nap for eva dunkley
for signing up with twitch prime i very
much appreciate that
um what else do we have going on
um oh i do have a bunch of memes
actually i got a bunch of memes remember
that
as i get memes i will put them up for
you here's the ones i got recently
so on the last stream someone asked me
if i'd put on weight
and i don't know where they got that
idea during the pandemic but i hadn't
i'm actually i weigh the exact same
amount as i did in senior year in high
school which is really crazy
but somebody sent me this this is me
pre-coronavirus on the left
and this is me post coronavirus on the
right
so that wasn't bad um you can send me
your memes
david davidpakman.com let's see what
else i've got
okay this is a similar idea someone just
i guess this is
like overweight david or something like
that
um my hair looks grainy that's weird it
looks like i have
sand in my hair as well so that's that
um oh okay this is david pakman show
bingo we've already gone over that
uh oh okay what happened here david just
a
heard a bad phone connection b ate an
unripened strawberry i would never do
that
c pondered how to hit a million
subscribers before the trump apocalypse
or d
all of the above it's c actually no it's
a
when i hear a bad uh phone connection
this is exactly how i react so there you
go it's not bad
um and then this is me when the pandemic
is over
and i don't know if this is a joke about
the pandemic is just
stressful or the pandemic is expected to
last 50 years
this is a good one now what's really
crazy is
this actually looks like my dad it looks
like an older version of my dad with
completely different hair but this
actually does look
sort of like my dad which is wild i
guess it's
like some kind of app that ages me or
something like that
so there's that and then lastly
um oh yeah if anybody says they're not
going to bother voting
i immediately get into my car and drive
right over this one's pretty good
um i actually if what kind of vehicle am
i driving here this
whoa hold on a second this is from um
this is a picture from when i was what
what does anybody know what kind of car
this is it's like a european version of
isuzu or something like that
when i was last in france i rented this
stick
shift suv and drove it it's an opal
exactly i drove it from um paris
to all over france i drove it to dijon
i drove it to grey poupon that's a joke
you guys understand right now i drove it
to dijon and
uh where did i end up i forget where i
ended up somewhere near the
paris near the italian border in any
case yeah it was a stick shift opal
diesel was it diesel i don't remember it
the story's more interesting if we say
it was diesel so we'll go with it
okay we are live in the room here
standing by for donald trump wild and
erratic at the top of the hour
expecting him to do things we've only
ever read of we are also in the middle
of a level two hype train on twitch
we've got three minutes to make it to
level three
rocco's modern life has helped us and
says from the standpoint of subs no one
has ever
seen a three-month twitch sub like this
keep up the great work david thank you i
will oceanova
subscribed for 13 wait 13 months
we've only been on twitch for 10 months
how is that possible
that's weird i don't understand that
anyway 13 months at tier 1 okay
says loving these david fat man memes
and not my corn has also subscribed all
very exciting
over on my website lynn reed has
subscribed and is new member number
three today
at joinpakman.com also gavin sanderson
is new member number four today and
james patterson new member number five
don't want to forget connor anderson
who's new member number six i haven't
even pitched membership yet i haven't
done a hard sell membership pitch yet
and we've got six people already which
is amazing
super chats continue to come in as we
reach a level three hype train
uh c says if democrats nuke the
filibuster what can they do that they
likely couldn't do
if the filibuster was there that's
actually the question
i don't know the answer to that and
recently there have been a lot of
interesting pieces both in favor of and
against nuking the filibuster
and the question is i mean listen a
relevant question is
who will control the senate after
january 20th because depending on the
answer to that you may be more or less
inclined to try to nuke the filibuster
right now so that's a great question
don't have the answer
we we need to figure out the answer
darkchip says trump found a new way to
make money by banning tiktok
yeah he still hasn't done it by the way
carl rosenstock has grabbed a membership
for eva dunkley says can you please add
timestamps to the member uploads to
denote different stories
and live stream start times love the
show keep up the good work we will look
into that
we will look into that chris riddle says
take your
mail-in ballots to the post office you
can certainly walk them over to the post
office of course
simp king says whoa what does simp king
say
could you dm kyle kolinsky on twitter
just saying hi kyle
i i we d we usually text i don't know
why i would do that
james acosta says can people who are
able start volunteering for the usps to
help with the cuts or can they hire more
people to help
well they're not going to be allowed to
hire more people due to budget
restrictions and you can't volunteer to
deliver mail as far as i know
thank you to tiny boy blunder musk
manatee
muskie manatees raisman 18 endes
tenavres traveling fever
and i burn easy who have all gifted
subscriptions and signed up
and have us now dangerously close to a
level 5 hype train
and on that note sunny08 with the
message
always doing a great job has pushed us
into
a level five hype train incredible
incredible um pair tieren hey
pearce says trump reminds of caligula
but instead
of sister it's daughter
addy says i'm getting my plasma infused
clorox later yeah
convalescent plasma but i don't like
this i actually prefer
p-l-o-z-m-u-h as the spelling for plasma
chelsea thomas says conservatives keep
saying universities indoctrinate
students with left-wing ideology
do they ever provide legitimate evidence
for this they claim to
but um
that's a complicated that's a big topic
and it's a topic for
for another day we have enabled some
bttv
emotes on twitch and emotes we've
actually enabled both
i don't know if they are all the right
ones the ones that people wanted but we
did absolutely enable a whole bunch of
them
um
emotes yeah there you go okay
kwb says out of control trump attacks
journalists with word salad
that's a good one actually that's a good
um that that's a good topic for a future
stream stefan robbins says
david if you beat sam cedars sam cedar
to 1 million subscribers what do you
think he should have to do
something humiliating i hope i have no
idea how many subscribers sam even has
so that's actually a funny question i
have no idea
is he is he might be very close to a
million already i don't know how likely
that is
um but i'll think about that stephen
peter ferritia says ever notice trump
never refers to pence as the vice
president but only as mike i have
noticed that
sinful solution says i like that fork
but merely for optics
yeah there's actually a lot of foods
like there are also desserts
here so let me actually give you an
example i think this might
infuriate some people and this could be
the this could be fodder for memes
earlier i was asked do i eat mac and
cheese with a fork or a spoon i said i
eat it with a fork for optics because
eating with a spoon seems almost like
you know i eat soups with a spoon
and then otherwise it feels very dessert
like so i'll even even for a very saucy
mac and cheese i would opt for a fork
i eat tiramisu
with a spoon even though a fork is
probably
more appropriate particularly because
with the with the straight
tines you can probably scoop up that
mascarpone
more easily than with the curvature of a
spoon i believe it's more logical to eat
tiramisu with a fork but i eat it with a
spoon
because i feel like the optics are
what's that guy doing over there
is that guy eating dessert or not
because he's got a fork
i'm signaling i'm virtue signaling that
i'm eating dessert
by using a spoon so i know that that may
be infuriating to a lot of people
but it is what it is we have about a
minute and 50 seconds left
to hit a hundred percent level five hype
train we're at 64
right now i do eat pie with a spoon
that's exactly right
i don't even like pie but if i have to
eat pie
i tend to eat it with a spoon even
though very often
common sense would dictate that we would
use a fork but i don't want to be you
know i don't want to be like george
costanza eating a snickers bar with
knife and fork
you know what i'm saying i don't want to
be doing that okay
um charlie says david do you think trump
beats corn on the cob like michael buble
i don't even know what that means so i
wouldn't be able to comment on that
christian gaffield says here's a fiver
for last week's whoa whoa whoa
stop the clock ronnie's the man yes a
lot of people
noticing the howard stern reference last
week whoa whoa whoa stop the clock
denzel tiddle has subscribed on youtube
christine says has coveted trumpism
impacted viewership of your show
yeah we had the best month ever on
youtube in july we had 19 million views
and 40
000 new subscribers in july best month
we've ever had
um so yeah i think people are staying
home i think my message is getting out
more widely i think there is more
interest in politics
um and we have reached level five hype
over on twitch um what else did i have
to mention
a lot a lot happening here geez the new
microphone as some of you are noticing
we the i'm so happy with the way the new
mic is sounding you know when i first
got the mic i just connected it and i
left my settings as they were for my
previous microphone
and then various audio professionals
told me you know
you can actually make it sound better
with different audio settings and we
tweak them
i listened to last week's show i rarely
do that but i actually listened to it
not a bad show i have to tell you
um and it was sounding beautiful i
actually believe
this is the best that the show has
arguably ever sounded
um and that's very exciting bay photo
says our savvy business president
failed to use covet as an opportunity to
sell maga masks it actually would have
been a win for his campaign and our
health
absolutely very very good point peter
stewart says love the show david three
months until election day
you know i know it not forgetting that
diane diane marzany says whoa hold on
where'd that go
diane mars and he says not surprising
the critical tweet about berks
don't ever say anything about the orange
man yeah
not allowed to critique the orange man
that we've learned
many many times per tiran says dijon now
i
envy you i love dijon mustard yeah when
i was in dijon
france i bought a bunch of dijon mustard
and it was
it's as good as you can imagine
okay richard b says do you think
massachusetts and other new england
states will be hit hard again by the
virus i'm worried that we will yeah
new cases have already doubled here in
massachusetts from 200 a day to
closer to 400 a day uh you can only
you know if we're all in the same pool
you can only pee in the deep end for so
long before the current
um brings you close to the p even if
you're in the shallow end
that's the analogy i used last week and
i think it's appropriate
for describing the current situation let
me
just very briefly say as we are waiting
here for donald trump
i want to give you a very special
invitation to come and grab a membership
at joinpakman.com
we are primarily funded by people who
say hey you know what
i can afford a dollar eighty a month and
i like what david does or i don't but i
think it's important either way
and i'm gonna grab a membership at
joinpakman.com
a lot of people because of you know what
trumpco v20
have canceled memberships and in fact
there have been periods over the last
four months where the cancellation rate
has exceeded the subscription rate and
that's not good
so this is our 15-year anniversary month
today is the first
weekday it's kind of like our first day
of the month august 1st was saturday
so my goal is to bring in more new
members than ever in a single month this
month where we're hitting 15 years
so consider grabbing a membership at
joinpakman.com we're doing the show
regardless if you can't pay that's okay
i don't want anyone's last dollar but if
you can spare two bucks a month or a
dollar 80 a month
you can use that coupon code 2020 now
and get yourself
a membership i am doing everything i can
to be a good
employer we were only somewhat affected
by the virus so i skipped getting ppp
money i had the opportunity to get ppp
money
i said there's limited money i'm not
gonna do it now needless to say
now it seems maybe there's money left
over or not there's scams i don't know
uh we uh pay for half of everybody's
healthcare right so we don't just leave
people we don't have to provide health
care we're a small employer
we pay for half of everybody's health
care because that's what we can do
and i'm looking into retirement right
we're do i try to do the right stuff and
we're primarily
able to do these things because people
grab memberships at jointpacman.com so i
will thank everybody who gets
such a membership including peter
cejecki
peter trajecki is new member number
seven today
david medford is new member number eight
today
brenda kelly you were new member number
nine thanks brenda
and i think that that gets me caught up
oh someone noticed so we had this
membership code in july which was july
surprise
and it was supposed to end we didn't
really delete the coupon code so it is
an unpublished membership code and
people are using it
listen have at it i don't we just want
people involved uh there there is an
unwritten
uh an unpublished coupon code july
surprise all one word all lower case
it'll work
it'll work if you choose to use it
um other super chats that are coming in
anina says keep it up sarang sheth
says trump was an undefeatable force
when he had cambridge analytica telling
him what to say
it's scary to think how powerful their
data sets were very scary
aquatic llama says any way to help the
postal service volunteering or something
yeah we had someone ask that earlier not
that i'm aware of
chukkuseki says shout out to my sister
vasuda
you rock pacman thank you r.r
rujin says i think trump is going to
have an aneurysm on camera
the manhattan d.a officially announced
the investigation
into trump for fraud into trump's
business not into trump remember that's
an important
detail for people asking about chess
streams this week i will be streaming
today
at 6 45 pm eastern time with one of the
top chess players in the world
grand master hikaru nakamura that will
be today at 6 45 pm eastern i am
in training for something called pog
champs 2.
it's a big chess tournament on chess.com
uh and in about an hour and 45 minutes i
will be streaming with hikaru nakamura
today
he will be streaming i will be streaming
and i expect
it's gonna be absolutely wild it's gonna
be wild and i do have
you know one of the things i want to
talk to hikaru about is
do grand masters when they meet somebody
who's not good at chess
does that make them think less of that
person's general
intelligence in other words do grand
masters look at someone like me
who is not very good at chess and say
how smart could he really be if he can't
figure out how to get better at chess
i'm interested in whether grandmasters
see chess skill as a proxy to general
intelligence or not
so i'm going to be talking to him i want
to ask him about that
so that's a later stream and that's
going to be a twitch only stream so i
hope that
you will join me a little bit later
that's at 6 45 and this trump press
briefing was scheduled to start
nine minutes ago let's see if donald
trump has tweeted about any delay
um no delay announced very few people in
the room which is
a little bit of a scary sign thanks to
jellybean
and kino hermes for signing up with
twitch prime
also mordengard has signed up the bad
wolf
and high level ideas um
anonymous gifter has gifted a
subscription to donald trump's hair
which is very polite
clockwork pineapple says i eat soup with
a fork
you utter casual yeah that's never
occurred to me
pepes says i want to know if trump and
family started shell companies to sell
hydroxychloroquine to the government
only reason they would push it so hard i
don't think that's the case i think it's
basically just political
um i think that the reasons they keep
pushing hydroxy are political
matt chavez says two weeks have expired
where's trump's health care plan yeah
um two weeks and a day ago donald trump
told chris wallace that
yesterday he would be signing into law a
completely new health care plan to
replace obamacare
nobody i mean i didn't believe it but
the two weeks have come and gone
hopefully there will be a question asked
about it today
breaker19 says isn't it bonkers how
almost the entire task force has denied
denounced hydroxychloroquine
but trump doubles down gr glad to see
berks catching heat finally yeah i've
been going after berks for months
thanks to mary beth woben and nina
and evelyn lee barney for signing up on
youtube
you have not missed anything trump is
just running late that's all
uh pamela goodman has grabbed a
subscription
over on twitch which is appreciated
penn hassan says deepak pog champ
deepak pog champ etc etc yes a frequent
refrain
eric lamont well where did that go
eric lamont says it occurred to me that
the anti-science coveted response in the
u.s is analogous to the climate change
fight
a scary preview of our future on that
front i think it is analogous yeah
memnoch the devil has subscribed at the
beta level
pear tiran says like you lazy
millennials and
others yet listen i would love it for
you to hit the like button
on youtube but i would much more
appreciate it if you hit the subscribe
button
why because we are in a race against
time and race for the future of humanity
trying to reach 1 million youtube
subscribers by election day
thanks to you we have moved up the
expected date
by two weeks we were last week we were
expected to hit a million subscribers on
july
january 9th thanks to you it is now
december 26th we've moved it up 14 days
okay every time somebody smashes that
subscribe button
we are potentially closer to hitting the
goal of a million subscribers
by november 3rd election day so
please hit the like button much more
important
as you know hit that subscribe button
and
we're i'm going to do everything i can
to get to that million and i am taking
suggestions about what we should do to
celebrate for sure
okay i have so many people i need to
thank who have signed up on my website
every one of them special in their own
way uh
joel filomino is new member number
jorge arroyo is new member number 11.
just wait uh justin shaw is new member
number 12
michelle iserman is new member number 13
and kristen lorenzen is number 14 today
martin horan and daniel dubois
get us to 16 new members kevin gable
and mars v girardin
are numbers 17 and 18 samuel
gazellius is number 19.
karen doherty and robert fox get us to
21.
holly hayes ins is number 22
kyle trojan is number 23
alex r is number 24. wow we are like
right there we are we are so close to
the goal of 25
as we await donald trump at the top of
the hour
um thank you to mowgliand queenie
for subscribing over on twitch danny
thompson says the real question is this
do you turn the spoon upside down once
it is in your mouth my son swears this
is the only way to use a spoon correctly
that's crazy danny no
absolutely not i take the spoon imagine
this is the spoon
i take my soup and then this is usually
my move right
upside down i don't even know how that
sounds bonkers
but although if i'm using a spoon for
something like
um tiramisu i might turn it upside down
just to lick the spoon
that is true i would potentially doing
that do potentially be doing that
i'm not ignoring uh twitch chat no
people there's a it's weird half of
twitch chat is about whether i'm paying
attention to twitch chat
it's really weird it's weird like kind
of look at me type stuff that's going on
odd um 82 swiffer says usa probably is
the divided states of america now yes to
some degree
stephanie sharp says my 21st is on
election day here's to a hell of a
birthday great show keep it up stephanie
i hope you have a good birthday in more
ways than one
waffles giraffe says how will we
rehabilitate the color orange one day
that's a good question that's a good
question
um philosopher has subscribed on youtube
chris says hey david it's my birthday
and this is the only live stream worth
listening to do you think next year the
usa will be able to travel to
europe chris happy birthday number one
and i do believe that
sometime in 2021 um
travel to europe will begin to normalize
and in fact i was just on the phone with
a friend who is camping out in
rural france and it sounds so
great and i'm going to be making some
phone calls after the stream today to
look into it it sounds much much better
much better than what's going on here in
the u.s thanks to bobby ship for the
subscription
betty poundser says david on your
subreddit a girl posted a story
about in high school you took her on a
date and spent an hour explaining
marxism versus leninism okay that never
happened and i don't even think that
there is such a post but i would love to
read it if it's actually there
in fact let me just on the off chance
that there is such a post
let me see if i can find it um
no there is no such post okay i fell for
it guys
i fell for it thanks to triple g grace
for subscribing on twitch at tier one
uh people asking how many twitch
subscriptions i have
9 22 9 22 as of right now
zesty african says should biden avoid a
debate with trump his staying quiet
seems to be working
listen i don't know if biden should
avoid a debate
what i can tell you is i don't care if
there are conventions i don't care if
there are debates
and i barely care who biden's vp pick is
as long as it's not you know like an
out white supremacist or something like
that um
the stakes are just so high that i don't
need to see them debate
i don't you know do they they're gonna
do whatever they want i have real no
real opinion
but i certainly don't need it to figure
out who i need to vote for
carmen edwards says usa needs to rethink
how we teach health class
probably we certainly need to rethink
how we teach critical thinking
black eyed dilly says any new info on
the false
national coveted numbers no not nothing
other than
we should from this point on be looking
at the numbers skeptically
i think is the way i would i would put
it
jason antunez has subscribed on youtube
rockwell says i hate your show but love
your microphone blah blah blah take my
last five bucks
i am so impressed with this microphone
you know i have three evr e20s
um strategically distributed
around the commonwealth of massachusetts
should i need to retreat
to um hiding places to do the show
were coveted to get really bad and i
don't have any
other than this sure sm 7b
i'm gonna need to buy a bunch of these i
think and leave them strategically
throughout the state uh as backups
because if there were to be an emergency
i don't want to go back to the evr e20
now that this is sounding so beautiful
um but yeah i do appreciate uh the
compliments on the microphone i didn't
build it but i did choose it
i bought it and for that i guess i need
some credit maybe
yeah my prepping is mostly stashing
microphones around the country
okay let's see here jake says i can't
believe
people fall for epic times yeah
fiann faber has signed up at the soyboy
level whoa
where's hal hal says sometimes you are
using trump lingo like beautiful or
strong is that on purpose or are we
brainwashed yeah i'm doing it
i'm doing it as a joke brad rogers sends
a super chat just go travel and cajun
girl have signed up
thanks to pepsi zombie and governor
slots
for signing up on twitch also sid has
subscribed with twitch prime which i
very much appreciate that
um am i hiding microphones in other
countries
not yet not yet
let's see here other subscribers on my
website
justin schneiderman gets us to number
25. guys
let's go for 50. let's see if we can do
it garrison brandon is number 26 on my
website today
lisa duncan and trenton ward get us to
28.
amy maloney and asim amin
get us numbers 29 and 30 today also want
to say hi
to daniel drake j
kies ricardo andreola
and amrit para julie getting us to
34 new members today wow
also sue berg and chris olig
get us to 36. david marble
david colabella and felix arwin get us
to 39.
holy [ __ ] we might actually get to 50
new members today this is insane
and annie o'connor is number 40. wow
wow gonna need a breather after that
brutal what is happening right now
brutal
uh thanks to beth us for subscribing
over on twitch
uh yes again people are asking if this
is the hikaru stream
no at close to seven pm eastern today
i'm scheduled to do a live
co-stream with grand master hikaru
nakamura i hope you'll join me for that
it's going to be a very very interesting
stream i predict
and i look forward to seeing you there
that'll be twitch only twitch.tv slash
david pakman
skunk game says what's the over under on
trump walking out during questions
double or nothing it's caitlyn collins
that triggers it yeah that's exactly the
way it would go down
shannon bennett says did you and scott
adams patch things up i don't think so
let's take a look and see if he still
has me blocked actually first let's see
if we've moved up the million subscriber
date
still 12 26 that's sad
yeah if you're watching on youtube
remember what was that it was weird
anybody hear that that was strange um
if you were watching on youtube please
do hit that subscribe button because we
are
hoping to get to a million subscribers
by election day let's see
scott adams says let's see if he still
has me blocked hold on
whoops i misspelled it
scott adams says yep
still blocked yeah we had a falling out
where i basically said i didn't agree
with something that he said and i
thought that he was acting in bad faith
and he
went on an f word rant and blocked me
months ago
and um there he is yeah i
i think you know i don't want to say
anything about him but i think he he may
he may be struggling
with more than just bad political takes
let me put it that way
um surya agarwal says just a fun fact
i'm indian and back home we call modi a
different version
of trump that makes sense to me that
makes a lot of sense rob shooter pj
walkling kenny redmond have all
subscribed on youtube
amy gray says thank you for doing these
live streams i really enjoy them thank
you for watching them
if you weren't here i wouldn't be doing
it amy
thanks to darkhar druid and duke leisure
as well as
yeatman og for the twitch
subs tyler and the resident says what
are some good argentinian foods i should
try that i can find in a grocery store
or buy online thanks
i mean you can't really you can't really
buy them in a grocery store there is
this website that sells a lot of
argentinian products
this is not a sponsor by the way it's
called pampa direct
i order from here all the time i'll show
you some of my favorite
argentinian snacks that i uh loved as a
kid and i still order we'll turn the
volume up here so we will hear it if
they go to it
here are some of my favorite items okay
jorgito alfajores this is a classic item
highly highly recommend this
by the way if anybody does order from
this website let them know i sent you
but i order from here all the time
they're not a sponsor
these are these are awesome okay um
okay chocolinas this is a fantastic
chocolate cookie
and you can make a cake where you soak
these in espresso and then
layer them with dulce de leche
unbelievable unbelievable
what else do we have okay um
this this uh these assorted bagley
cookies
i don't even know if these are actually
argentinian they're so famous in
argentina when i was a kid
my favorite snack in argentina was hot
chocolate with some of these cookies
absolutely fantastic well this brings
back memories this is wild
um what else do we have a lot of do oh
this is a classic
this is a chocolate covered banana but
it's a fake banana filling
the smell of it is such a nostalgic
smell for me i recently ordered a
bunch of boxes last time i was in
argentina in fact i went into a little
kiosk
and said how many do you have and they
were like i've got two boxes and i was
like yeah give them to me he's like how
many i'm like no no
give me both boxes like these were these
were not boxes labeled for retail sale
these were the boxes that the store uses
to display them i was like
i'm taking both boxes back to the u.s
beautiful day
uh what else do we have
other items that were my favorites
this is pretty good right here oh these
right oh my god
this this brand right here these cookies
this is one of my
we'll just end on this i'm not going to
go through the full list
this is i believe that this is an item
that could
basically trigger world peace this is
such a fantastic cookie
that if these were distributed in a sort
of humanitarian mission
this could end world conflict right here
this is like nothing i've ever had
classic classic item 36 cookies for 23
bucks oh that's not bad that's like 75
cents a cookie i like that
anyway those are some of my favorite uh
favorite items
but i actually got a big order yesterday
of argentinian items from a local
argentinian bakery if you follow me on
instagram you would know about it i post
i posed
holding my boxes of empanadas and stuff
yesterday that's on my instagram page
okay let's conti i don't want to go too
far off there
it's a fantastic cookie absolutely um
all right let's see what else we've got
oh people some people are angry that i'm
talking about cookies okay well listen
you can you can leave if you want
um smig says have you looked into brett
weinstein's unity 2020 proposal for a
candidate duo computed of a democrat
composed of a democrat and a republican
yeah wasn't it like andrew yang and um
admiral or general mcraven i mean
okay it's interesting but it's going to
be biden or trump the election is
you know people start voting in four and
a half weeks
hayden sanford says what's your take on
the death penalty for the boston
marathon bomber i'm against the death
penalty in general so am i
and there's about eight different
reasons why i'm against the death
penalty i've outlined them extensively
in a whole bunch of different videos and
i'm against the death penalty in total
so i don't know that i
feel the need to say more of that right
now kyle craven says orange how will we
rehabilitate
the color red again lol make red hats
wearable again michael roano says can
you sum up why trump always talks badly
about the cdc and who
i always get mixed up with which one he
dislikes he mostly attacks
the who i mean listen with trump it's
anything he can do to to just
redirect blame elsewhere that's all it
is and attacking the who is an
opportunity to do that
okay people asking if we are at 50 new
members let's see aaron
ibanez is new member number 41.
mary jane umick is new member number 42.
cindy pifer is new member number 43.
steven stanton and andrew newton get us
to 45.
jean-pierre gary eppie is number 46
ben wait did i mention ben triple yeah
no ben tripp is number 47.
robert meyer is number 48
andrew morner is number 49 so i think we
are just one shy
one shy no chad atterbury is number
50 wow wow let's go for 75. i mean why
let's just try to keep it going it's an
unbelievable day
uh people in the chat positive about
empanadas some people upset about
empanadas
wow that's sad who could be upset about
an empanada
uh we are you didn't miss anything yet
we are a half hour late for donald
trump's
um coronavirus press briefing of sorts
i do have another stream scheduled for 6
45 if they don't get on with it i might
have to pinch off this stream in order
to start the next one which would be sad
i am jean says sam cedar and david
parkman
to 1 million subscribers go
jb says happy i caught the livestream
thank you and keep up the amazing work
thank you hound dog says i'm very
anxious about the election what is your
overall feel for how things are going to
go now that we're exactly three months
from november third
my feeling is we have to so overwhelm
the vote
that it's not even close and so voter
suppression won't work
we have to overwhelm the vote they're
going to pull out every stop
every single stop that they can and
that's why we just need to
have the highest turnout ever and i know
we say that many elections
but if we don't then trump may get
himself re-elected
thanks to jimmy stylen for the support
on twitch
ketec kite cutie maybe better said
is a new twitch prime subscriber across
has subscribed on twitch
see cam fewest has subscribed with
prime as well people on twitch asking
why it always starts late
your guess is as good as mine narcissism
um i i you know disdain for the media
i don't know it just they're always late
kendra hamblin says can we talk about
the questions think jfk jr is coming
back from the dead to be trump's vp
i don't know what that means i don't
even know what that means i'm sorry
peasant media says staged assassination
of trump eminent expect steve bannon
backed false flags
to suspend elections i i'm going to
chill with that
steiner husby says best of luck on the
race to a million
youtube subscribers do you think the
trump administration is praying for
left-wing stochastic terrorism against
them or their followers
when they let trump hint about delaying
the election i
certainly hope not i certainly hope not
now it is really weird that they are now
starting to mess with the lights because
this was scheduled for a half hour ago
already um let's see if there was any
rescheduling on the official white house
schedule
no still scheduled for five this is now
definitely starting to get very weird
for sure
very very strange
um thanks to ayub abu kharat for the soy
boy level subscription
moonlight sends a super chat just go
travel says hey david henrik here henrik
from denmark hey henrik
5 a.m says thoughts on yale's doctor
whoops where did that go
oh boy i lost it where did that go
thoughts on yale's dr harvey rich saying
hydroxychloroquine is effective on
high-risk patients
but over-politicization stunted research
didn't see it glad to look at it but i
think we've
it's probably time to move past the uh
hydroxy
conversation few other subscribers
joshua torres is new member number 51
caleb wagoner is number 52
very much appreciate the support at
joinpackman.com
pez player and laroche as well as monkey
ninja
have grabbed twitch subscriptions thank
you for that
jimmy bignah oh wait joe krockenberg
says
trump is not putting forth any populist
ideas this time around he's only
pandering to his base and states he won
last time
i think he loses badly i hope you were
right
jimmy big nuts says can you raid into
the serf's tv when you're done
uh maybe i i mean i will see i might be
raiding hikaru because i'm going to be
joining his stream after but i'm going
to be doing something with lance from
the surfs very soon and i think you're
going to like it
i think it's going to be very very good
um
jake says is there to wait a way to get
accurate cuvid 19 numbers that i don't
know
that i don't know at this point who
knows
let's see here 82 swiffers says
greetings from germany appreciate your
show thank you we appreciate our german
subscribers
um okay some people talking about i
should start calling it
cuvid19 corvid19
some people call it coved uh trump kovi
20
maga flu trump flu um
there's endless names for it cobb fe19
the various 19 the varys virus yeah
cuphead i like cuff it's not bad
actually i like that
um
okay i guess that's as far as we're
going with that alexander
hakistad says keep up the good work
happy to see that there are people like
you making sense of the weird stuff
going on in the u.s
all the best from norway love it
mr platonic panda says shout out from
the panda
panda consortium or consortium as some
say
love your show katie bradshaw says hello
from maine i appreciate your coverage
here i have a lot of friends
um hunkering down in maine which i think
is an interesting place to be
thanks to desiree dickey's chef
who is new member number 53 these are
some crooked numbers
um steve turmell
is new member number 54
terminal turmoil yeah i think i got that
right
uh and also lastly
dylan clutter who's new member number 55
today
we've never really had numbers like
these before i have to admit
in full transparency we've never seen it
before
intel jesus has grabbed a twitch prime
subscription
so has kabuki dad kabuki dad is a great
guy
great father mark davis says the
republican representative steve watkins
for the district i live in kansas 2
has been charged with voter fraud i saw
that that's an interesting story
thanks to dylan clutter for the double
subscription signing up at the beta
level
on youtube alejandra torres
is new a new youtube member sandria
guest says i didn't know you were
stashing microphones good
good idea bacon lover says thoughts on
the new magic the gathering ban list
i have no idea i played magic the
gathering
twice in my life life with former david
pakman
show producer louis motomety he's big
into it he plays online
he plays in person he's playing all over
the place um
but i i couldn't tell you anything about
magic the gathering it is very much not
my thing
todd half acre and clarence wheeler have
subscribed on youtube
matt says the sm7b is a great mic for
death metal vocals so good choice in
case your career path goes in that
direction
yeah i mean listen if we get totally
destroyed on a million subs
and i end up having to do something
different because i get essentially
embarrassed off of youtube
i have the microphone to go into death
metal and i think that that's a great
thing
uh let's see here okay we have live
video on the white house feed which to
me signals that this is going to be
starting very soon so we'll switch over
there
um
getting a little loud in there in fact
maybe i'll just turn it down a little
bit
just go travel says just go travel
equals hendrick equals a thousand us
dollars yeah
j so henrik from denmark
made a thousand dollar
some people call it patreon i call it
patreon pledge
uh an incredibly incredibly
generous pledge on patreon or
patreon.com
david pakman show great to see you
in the super chat henrik very much
appreciate it
thanks to d stover and eileen
patonic arnold as well as jason nadal
for the youtube subs bay photo says
david's national mike stockpile is our
stockpile that's right
this this stockpile of microphones i
have it's for us
it's not for the federal government it's
for the states which is why i'm leaving
microphones in different states jim
clark says what if trump is actually
coherent and articulate today i'll have
to change the stream title yeah that's
true
scott phantasm says hey david just
wanted to say i appreciate your channel
and all that you do that's a very nice
message scott thank you
uh garrett hill has subscribed at the
soy boy level so has david gises
and here he is the mango menace himself
the tangerine
terror
thank you very much i want to start by
providing
information on our response to tropical
storm
essay yes very interesting name
okay last week the storm hit puerto rico
and the virgin islands
and i've issued emergency declarations
to support our response in both
of those areas trump cares about puerto
ricans that's the message
this week the storm passed just east of
florida
got a little bit lucky didn't hit
florida too hard working with the
governor working with everybody but it
did not hit directly
as a lot of people thought it might it's
currently off the coast of south
carolina heading northward
to north carolina is expected to make
landfall sometime this evening as a
category one hurricane
very serious a lot of water a lot of
water coming a lot of water from the
standpoint of water already issued
emergency declarations for florida
south carolina north carolina and fema's
personnel and they are great they're
doing a job they're
already on the ground in all areas every
single area that we mentioned is covered
over the next several days there's
expected to be heavy wind and rain
in the coastal areas of north carolina
virginia maryland delaware new jersey
we're working with each of those states
and in particular as it relates to fema
the military law enforcement all of the
different groups that are involved storm
surge and
inland flooding are possible and
everyone needs to remain vigilant
until it passes nobody's heard you want
to follow the guidelines of the state
and local authorities we're working
with them and i think the guidelines
have been very accurate so far so
stay safe next
let me provide an update on the path
forward for our country as we
continue our war to defeat the china
virus
oh god we're beginning to see evidence
of significant progress nationwide the
number of positive cases has declined by
nearly six percent
from the week before and the positive
test rate has also dropped from eight
point seven to
eight percent over that same period of
time an encouraging sign
very encouraging statistical noise the
virus is receding
in hot spots across the south and west
we've seen slow improvements
from their recent weekly peaks arizona's
weekly case counts have dropped 37
percent
that's a tremendous drop in the governor
and the state have done a fantastic job
down 37
texas down 18.7 percent i was there a
couple of days ago
and florida 21.2 percent drop so that's
a tremendous
uh job that they're all doing remember
we simply can't trust the case numbers
anymore so this is of of
arguably limited value new flare-ups in
the states where the case numbers have
risen
including georgia mississippi tennessee
oklahoma missouri and
i think you'll find that they're soon
going to be very much under control
meanwhile 18 states continue to have
very low case numbers and low test
positivity rates under 5 percent alaska
connecticut delaware illinois maine
maryland
massachusetts michigan montana new
hampshire new jersey new york
north dakota oregon rhode island vermont
west virginia and wyoming
it's under five even in these states
however
where the virus is under control and at
a very low number
americans should continue to be vigilant
be careful
in order to prevent the new hot spots
from opening up or any new hot spots
from
opening up in those states to that end i
urge all americans to continue to
socially distance
wash your hands wear a mask when you
cannot avoid
crowded places and to protect the
elderly
very very important protect the elderly
it's much different young children have
very strong immune systems we've learned
how strong they are
but protect the elderly the average age
of those who succumb to the virus is
78 years old that's the average age
it's important for all americans to
recognize that a permanent lockdown is
not
a viable path towards
producing the result that you want or
certainly not
a viable path forward and would
ultimately
inflict more harm than it would prevent
not if it was coordinated and done
properly once right that's that's the
idea
are once again surging of many places
where we thought they were under control
and doing a great job and they are doing
a great job but this is a
very tough invisible enemy lockdowns do
not prevent infection
in the future they just don't it comes
back many
times comes back the purpose of a
lockdown is to buy time to build
capacity
especially as it respects to with
respect to hospitals
learn more about the disease and develop
effective treatments as we
did in the united states we're doing
very well with the vaccine does he
mention hydroxy or not what do you guys
think countries where there
have been very significant flare-ups
over the last
short period of time or spain germany
france australia
japan and also as you probably heard in
hong kong they've had some very
serious flare-ups japan has gone
yeah a lot a lot of uh six-fold
six-fold flare-up that's a lot but
they'll get it under control
in our current phase we must focus on
protecting those at highest risk while
allowing younger and healthier americans
to resume work
and school with careful precautions
i think one school already had like 100
people test positive or something crazy
i mean it's wild what's going on
continuing to drive down the mortality
rate with improved care
treatment and medical interventions
building a bridge to the introduction of
a vaccine the vaccines are coming along
incredibly well
today i'd like to also provide an update
on the actions of my administration
and the work that we've done
we're taking really taking an increased
interest and we're seeing numbers that
nobody can even believe in terms of
percentage increase it's telehealth for
american patients the
the percentage increase is being worked
on right now but it's very very
significant numbers that you would not
even think possible
this has been a priority from the
beginning of my administration when we
launched an initiative to allow veterans
to
connect remotely with their va
healthcare team
and it worked out really well we have a
91 approval rating in the va
in terms of the job we're doing there's
the first it's the highest
ever recorded now telehealth is a
critical part of our
path forward in the va and it's becoming
a critical path
especially with our senior citizens you
don't have to go to the doctor's office
you don't have to go to hospitals
when the invisible enemy struck our
shores i took
immediate action to eliminate regulatory
barriers to
telehealth making it easier for patients
to consult with doctors from
safety and convenience and really they
have
great safety and great convenience right
from their homes
today i'm taking action to ensure
telehealth is here to stay
moments ago in the oval office i signed
an executive order to make
many of our regulatory reforms permanent
we've done some regulatory reforms that
have had a
really tremendous impact on on what
we're doing on
medicine and medical and what we're
doing they can do things that you
wouldn't believe
that even a year ago two years ago would
not have been
doable we're enshrining the right of
american patients to meet with their
medical providers in a way
that is best for them and very very
convenient and very talented people on
the other side of the line i have to
tell you
the order builds upon a series of
actions we've
all taken to make telehealth available
to all
it's always funny to me how like they
come out with this material
this stuff is never reported on in any
serious way like it's just nonsense
the the the questions are what are
actually noteworthy here
for telehealth services we are working
very hard also on prescription drug
prices and i will tell you that the
favorite nations laws that i've signed
into
existence nobody thought anybody would
ever do that has a massive
impact on prescription drug prices right
in addition to the three other elements
elements
reduction of of uh drugs
particular prescription drugs elements
of reduction of drugs
the favorite nations laws is massive for
instance if germany buys a pill
for 10 cents a pill as an example just
as an example
and the united states pays two dollars
for the same pill
we get the same privilege the same right
as they do never had that before
we paid all of the expenses all of the
research and development
so the uh okay the numbers are
astronomical as you probably noticed uh
big ads are taken against me by
big pharma very big ads very massive
buy big big ads but in the meantime
they're calling they want to know if
they can make a deal
and i say to people the only reason
these ads are being taken is because
prices are coming down for you
and they understand that i think our
people understand that
but in particular when you look at the
matching you could call it matching or
you could call it favorite nations
it's a tremendous uh it's going to have
a tremendous and i'm talking about 50 60
70 that doesn't mean it goes to set 10
cents as an example but theirs comes up
and ours goes down and you have many
many countries where
uh their numbers the numbers are so low
i mean so low and by that i mean much
lower than the united states
no one can believe another thing i'm
doing is if a certain country
like canada canada buys for very much
less than the united states has bought
how they allowed this to happen
representatives of our country
standing at these podiums or in the oval
office how they allowed this to happen
is just to me incredible we've been
working on this for a long time
i've been talking about it with kaylee
for a long time
right so now uh a governor like i think
she's been his press secretary for like
seven weeks a great governor of ohio
or a great governor of any state can
call up and
buy the drugs directly from canada at
sometimes 50 percent less so we'll be
buying from canada now what the drug
companies are going to do
maybe they'll raise them maybe they'll
lower them or maybe they'll just give up
and sell them to us directly much
cheaper
so a lot of things are happening also
the rebate we have people that are very
wealthy that
nobody ever heard of them nobody knows
who they are i guess in some cases they
can be pharmacies in some cases they're
individuals we're doing a rebate
and the rebate goes to the people it
lowers the price of drugs
so we have a series of four things that
we signed and
you will see over a period of fairly
short period drug prices are going to be
tumbling down
oh yeah numbers that nobody would have
ever believed possible
we have in 51 years the only time prices
came down was during this administration
it was last year 51 years it went up
but that was just a small decline
this is a massive decline this is a
decline that nobody can believe i was
called by senators oh we don't believe
it don't worry congressman
please don't do this but
big pharma doesn't mean anything to me
other than we want them to do a great
job we want them to get their vaccines
we want them to do
what has to be done so i think you're
going to see drug price reductions over
the next
four or five or six months probably take
a little while to kick in that are going
to be
at numbers that you would it is going to
take a little bit more time
on friday afternoon they want to meet
see if they can do something else they
don't like favorite nations clauses i
understand that
we've actually expanded coverage
allowing
medicare to cover more than 135 new
services
through telehealth by the way including
physical therapy
emergency department visits home visits
mental health counseling
substance abuse treatment which is a
very big priority
we brought the substance abuse at least
prior to the china plague or
whatever you want to call it we brought
it down very substantially
pediatric critical care and much more
thanks to our actions an estimated two
billion dollars of additional funding
will
support medicare patients receiving
telehealth
services so a very very big priority on
telehealth
as part of the cares act we secure 200
million dollars to help
healthcare providers and hospitals
expand their telehealth
right they're all doing it they're doing
it gladly prior to the
epidemic or the pandemic whatever you
want to say and how you want to refer to
it but
prior to the pandemic the
telehealth was fine but it wasn't
anything raging
and i guess one of the things that we've
gotten out of this whole
horrible situation is telehealth has
been incredible and
again the increases are uh you know
many hundreds of times greater than it
was uh does trump have any idea what
he's talking about guys
at 2 000 or something like that it's an
incredible
it's an incredible increase yes mr
president but it's it's uh i think they
have it now finally
yeah and it's really an incredible thank
you kaley we work with the
leaders of major health insurance
companies to ensure coverage for the
telehealth visits related to coronavirus
we cut red tape to allow many services
to be conducted by phone rather than
video which is
much simpler providing a much easier
option for many seniors in particular 35
percent of the
medicare beneficiaries who receive
telehealth services
or over 3.6 million seniors
did so over the phone so you're talking
about 6.
3.6 million seniors that's something
10.1 million medicare beneficiaries have
accessed care through telehealth since
the beginning of the pandemic
so you're talking there 10.1 million
people
in april over 43 of all medicare primary
care visits were done via telehealth and
why compared to less than uh 0.1
in february those are really weaving
quite an elaborate story of how he's
handled everything perfectly right i
mean
my confidence in him is just
skyrocketing so think of that compared
to less than
point one percent point one percent
uh that's an incredible number so
over 43 percent of all medicare primary
care visits were done via telehealth
compared to
so you went from point one percent to
forty hit 160 000 dead people he's
talking about percentages of telehealth
in the va
the executive order i signed today will
also expand
health care access in rural america we
take care of
rural america it directs agencies to
deploy strategic investments in our
rural communications
infrastructure and we're working very
hard
with all of the people in government
that are involved with the
communications infrastructure so that
the
the telehealth gets very quick and easy
access
right additionally revenue for rural
providers
vary significantly from month to month
making it difficult for many
to stay in business many many years not
just that it seems like he doesn't
really care he actually doesn't seem
very bright
payment system that will give rural
hospitals flexibility really great
flexibility
and a more consistent income stream to
better serve their patients
furthermore i am directing the
department of agriculture department of
health
and human services and the federal
communications commission
we were just with the heads of each one
in the oval office
just before i came up to the podium to
form a task force that will
break down barriers to expanding rural
health care
this order continues my administration's
focus on
rural health care great slide we
allocated nearly
165 million dollars through the cares
act to support nearly 1
800 whole slide rural hospitals who have
done an incredible job
as well as 11.5 million dollars to
expand technical assistance for rural
and
underserved areas we allocated another
10 billion dollars to
2000 rural hospitals it's interesting to
say rural
that's not how i mean english is my
second language but that's not my
instinct
wave burdensome licensing certification
and registration requirements which took
tremendous amounts of time
and these are people that had great
reputations and great
track records for practitioners that
serve on the front lines in rural areas
allowing more medical personnel to serve
their wonderful patients we're also
in terms of ppe ensuring that the state
and local areas have
the supplies they need we've been
supplying
hospitals and cities and states
governors
something seems to be in the air there's
people getting banned like left and
right on youtube and twitch it's crazy
what's happening
in 40 nursing homes have received a
second shipment of personal
protective equipment they're very much
stocked up
they're in great shape they all have the
ventilators all the ventilators they
need they have actually more than they
need
and they're too much medical equipment
too many ventilations
they're full my administration has
worked with the private sector to
deliver over 100 million
n95 respirators 85 million gloves
and nearly 250 million face coverings
nationwide what about gowns
we continue to make the extraordinary
progress that we've been talking about
together on vaccines and
treatments under operation warp speed
which is very exciting
most exciting last week we distributed
two thousand
nine hundred and seventy nine cases of
rem disavir which is proving to be
extremely powerful and good right
enough to treat more than 19 000
patients had great results this
includes 500 cases for florida 500 for
texas 300 for california 200 for ohio
and 150 for arizona and georgia keep
listing and those numbers will be going
up rapidly as we
move along hospitals are reporting an
adequate
supply of steroids such as dexamethasone
that are used successfully in late stage
illness
please mention plasma very good we're
also very encouraged about the prospects
for
plasma therapies there it is and uh that
we're working on
and that's a brilliant argument oh man i
hope it coming
and we launched a national positive
drive last week i was at the red cross
building
every time with the american red cross
and 13 other health care
organizations i urge everyone
who has recovered from the virus to go
to coronavirus.gov
corona virus.gov and donate plasma today
we would really appreciate it this
really makes people better
but we need what we need is we need
oh my god beautiful ingredient that you
that got better
seem to have in your in your veins you
have to go to coronavirus.gov
and donate plasma today it would be
tremendous we really appreciate it if
you do it
because we're forward to close the nuh
we can help a lot more people
and uh it would be a terrific thing
it'll take an hour maybe a little bit
more than an hour
yeah but everybody will be very
appreciative makes people better
and hot why
knocked it out so we want to be able to
uh
use it so whatever you can do
coronavirus.gov
as a result of improvements we've made
in treatment for americans over the age
of 18
the mortality rate has declined 85
percent
from its april it's an indictment of
like 60 million americans that he's
president
like this guy's an idiot but also 60
million people voted for this it's an
indictment of them
csx to purchase and produce
100 million doses of their coronavirus
vaccine
100 million doses this is the sixth
vaccine candidate we are
proactively supporting we're supporting
numerous
companies that are doing very well
having wonderful results
and they're in final stages of testing
there are now two vaccines in the in
that final stage of
clinical trials in america with a third
vaccine likely to begin phase three
almost immediately
and we have additional clinical trials
scheduled over the next few weeks for a
couple of the other
companies these are great companies
these are companies that are not only
well known they're well respected most
importantly like
balancing speed and safety and we're
on pace to have a vaccine available this
year maybe
far in advance of the end of the year
and we're mass producing the most
promising candidates in advance so that
we're ready immediately upon approval we
have our military lined up
it's logistics it's all about logistics
they deliver a lot of things including
soldiers
but now they'll be doing vaccine our
general is all ready to go
and he's very excited and once we have
the vaccine approved fully approved
he'll start the process they will start
the process
and they'll get it out very very quickly
all over the country and maybe beyond if
it
works as we think it probably will by
unleashing america's technical and
scientific brilliance
we will end this pandemic and we will
hopefully end it very quickly
the therapeutics are very exciting to me
where you can go into a hospital and
whether it's through a
shot or a transfusion you take care of
somebody and they get better
that's something to me is very important
and we're doing really well on
therapeutics and really well on vaccines
so
uh thank you all very much for being
here we'll take a couple of questions
here we go
thank you mr president um your response
to two items in the news and ask a
question uh first do you have any have
you been briefed on the
incident off the coast of california
where uh the marines in the navy
department uh hospital then
kirk who died in a uh in a training
accident uh
they're actually briefing me in a little
while we have it scheduled for a little
while for you
to speak to the families it's terrible
and we'll be in contact with the
families
anything like that is terrible
separately today
the city prosecutor confirmed a criminal
investigation
from the trump organization do you have
any reaction to that
i just heard about it this is just a
continuation of the witch hunt
it's democrat stuff they failed with
mueller they failed with everything they
failed with congress they failed at
every stage of the game this has been
going on for
three and a half four years even before
i got in this was starting
with uh the mueller deal mueller started
a little bit after
but it started with some of the people
that you know very well
the names strzok and paige
and all of the different people call me
this has been going on this is a
continuation of the worst
witch hunt in american history and
there's nothing that i know even about
it you know they had i had seen that
today just a little while ago
and i said what's this all about i know
nothing about it but it's just a
continuation of the witch hunt
didn't work out for congress didn't work
out for mueller worked out
working out for anybody so what they're
doing is they send them around to all
over the country i guess maybe
but it's a it's a terrible thing that
they do it's really a terrible thing
the uh the witch hunt has gone on long
enough okay
you mentioned the vaccine development
program uh could you assure the american
people that
politics and considerations around the
election will not
interfere with the science absolutely
and i plan on playing a role in just
determining how the vaccine will if
there is one will be distributed across
the country is that something that you
would feel it's possible that i get
involved
but no it won't have anything to do with
we want to make people better
we want to send them to the areas that
most need it and i think we're going to
have something very soon it's going good
mr president you said today in a tweet
that dr burks was taking
date from speaker pelosi what did you
mean by that considering that she was
just describing the facts about the
case of the pandemic right now across
the country
well i think we're doing very well and i
think that
we have done uh as well as any nation if
you really look
you take a look at what's going on
especially now with all these flare-ups
it's
painful at this point to be saying stuff
like that we're much bigger than other
than
india and china china's having a massive
flare-up right now india has a
tremendous problem
other countries have problems and i
noticed that in the news and the evening
news i never read about that in any of
the news i don't read about the other
countries
you're starting to see that other
countries are having very big flare-ups
countries that thought they were over it
like we thought we might be over it in
florida and then all of a sudden it
comes back they do come back
but i think we're doing very well
i told dr burks i think we're doing very
well what's he talking about china look
at this
is a person i have a lot of respect for
i think nancy
pelosi's treated her very badly very
very badly very
nasty and i'm just referring to the fact
that i thought that
really they should say the job we've
done whether it's on ventilators or
testing we've tested
now over 60 million people no other
country is even close to that
we've tested 60 million people with
great in many cases about 50 percent now
rapid fire meaning
five to fifteen to twenty minute tests
where you get the result almost
immediately
nobody has anything like that nobody and
uh
i think we're just doing very well
just to follow up just quickly does that
mean you just with her characterization
mr president
thanks mr president um i want to follow
up on two things
that you said earlier in the counter
room the first was
uh on tick tock and the second was on
caron of ours on tick-tock you said that
you wanted money for the us treasury
from the sale
does that mean you expect the chinese
company to pay
the u.s treasury directly are you
talking about either way whether it's
microsoft or somebody else or it was the
chinese what what the price is
the united states could should get a
very large percentage of that price
because we're making it possible
without us you know i use the expression
it's like
the landlord and the tenant and without
the lease
doesn't have the value well we're sort
of in a certain way the least
small government no regulation give us
money for a transaction in between
companies
but a big portion of it's in this
country from the sale directly it would
come from the sale yeah whatever the
number is would it would come from
and then you know nobody else would be
thinking about but me but that's the way
i think and i think it's
i think it's very fair and you mentioned
but we want no security problems with
china
it's got to be an american company it's
going to be american security it's got
to be owned
yeah we don't want to have any problems
with security etc
and something could come out i will tell
you there's a lot of excitement not only
by microsoft
by other companies in terms of buying it
so we'll see what happens but we want
and we think we deserve to have a big
percentage of
that price coming to america coming to
the treasury
then on the negotiations on capitol hill
you've expressed some frustration said
you might take
executive action to address um
yes so i was wondering if you could talk
about both uh how you might prevent
evictions through executive action and
then also i can do that if i
want and i want to do that i don't want
people to be evicted and
you know when they're evicted when
they're thrown out of their whatever the
place may be
in many cases they go to big shelters
and if you
talk about pandemic this is a pandemic
and
they go to shelters number one they're
thrown out viciously it's not their
fault it's china's fault
it's not anybody's fault it's china's
fault right but number two and if they
are thrown out they
oftentimes will go to a shelter with
tremendous numbers of other people
and the the virus will spread and we
don't want that are you considering
suspending
payroll the collection of payroll taxes
i can do that also through an executive
order so we'll be talking about that but
we're having a very good discussion with
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
the problem do bailouts of their
various democrats run states and cities
and they want a lot of money they want
to trade trump wanted like 370 million
to renovate the white house or something
so the
you know glass house is throwing stones
something something trouble for years of
bad management
in all cases democrat run cities and we
don't think that's fair
you understand that you've heard it
before
thank you i wanted to ask you about the
justice department
sending federal agents into cities like
chicago as part of operation legend
how exactly do you envision these
federal forces working alongside local
police departments
it's not a mass send but it's sending
very talented
people to help them with the drugs and
the shootings and the guns and the
things that are happening
it's not like sending in the national
guard and stopping it cold
which is an example a lot of progress
has been made in portland but
you know frankly sitting in the national
guard like we did in
uh minneapolis it stopped it cold from
the time we sent that national guard
they walked down the street
it was over in minneapolis okay now it
may be starting up again this is
uh these are democrat-run cities and
states
and it hasn't been a pretty picture to
watch
we will help chicago we'll help new york
if they request after request to help
but we want to stop the drugs we want to
stop the guns a lot of
the chicago is guns and and but what it
is
is drug related gang related largely
gang related
with ice we send out thousands of ms-13
thousands and thousands of ms-13 we send
them back
or in some cases have to put them in
prison they're too violent they're truly
violent
uh so with helping out when you look at
what's happening in chicago and some
other cities
with the shootings and the killings they
need help
and we haven't met with resistance i
have to be honest with you i think it's
good that we haven't we're only looking
to help them
we're only looking to help he's there to
help oem
uh-oh thank you mr president in
in our nation's 243-year history there
has never been
a stronger push for mailing ballots to
determine a national election
yeah are you considering at any point
issuing an executive order
addressing mail-in ballots and uh why do
you think you can't do anything about
him
well there's never been a push like this
for male imbalance and if you look at
the
new york congressional race which is a
disaster
carolyn it's been a total disaster
they have they're six weeks into it now
they have no clue what's going on
and i mean i think i can say right here
and now i think you have to rerun that
race because it's a mess nobody knows
what's happening
with the ballots and the lost ballots
and the fraudulent ballots i guess
it's a good question which is he going
to try to stop mail-in ballots despite
the fact that these are state decisions
they said this is a small race with
literally thousands of people
small thousands and it's all messed up
you look at patterson new jersey it's
all messed up
almost every one of these and these are
small easy to control
they should be able to do this easy now
you're talking about like
nevada where last two nights ago they
they went out and in the darkness of
night without
people without having any meetings of
the public without having anything he
was triggered by this
ridiculous you don't have to look at
signatures you don't have to approve
anything you can have double mailings
you can have all sorts of things
nobody's ever seen
anything like it it's a disgrace i mean
honestly it's a disgrace
so it's a very good question i mean the
uh the mail-in ballots if you look at
just no answer by the way
small the small places the small races
of congressional race in new york
um should be very easy normally that
would have been announced at seven
o'clock and it would have been
down to the wire and everybody would
have loved it it was
it was at all complex it would have
taken an extra 45 minutes or an hour
they would have announced it a little
bit later
they have no clue this was about six
weeks ago
and they have no clue what's going on
they've lost ballots
the question is is he going to try to do
something federally about states running
elections
how are you going to do that for an
entire nation no answer they're using
covid to try and get
the mail-in ballots now absentee ballots
are great
we're talking about the same thing here
they request them they go through a
process they get them
but the universal mail-in ballots have
turned out they only go to registered
voters dude
nevada has been doing if you look over
the last few days
you have to look at what they've done
you can have two ballots
you can no you can't so you can take
thousands of ballots put them together
and just dump them down on somebody's
desk
no a certain period of time they have
something where
if you vote the vote can count up to
seven days later well if the vote's
going to count seven days later that
means you
you know if it depends on the one state
like nevada
that would mean simply that you can't
have supposing it's down it's not going
to depend on nevada
it's a great state but supposing it's
down to that one state
that means you have to wait seven days
but they won't have it there
this is something why don't we
prioritize getting it right rather than
doing it quickly
the post office for many many years has
um
you know run in a fashion that hasn't
been great
great workers and everything but the
other part of it very old equipment
and i don't think the post office is
prepared for a thing like this you have
to ask the people at the post office but
he's kneecapping his people are running
the post off he's like yeah talk to
somebody at the post office
louis de joy his donor is now running
the post office
john and these companies doing you know
all the buying instead of going to a
department store they go
buy through mail so you have massive
numbers of
purchases now going through the post
office purchases of items and gifts
and that's a tremendous strain on the
post office the post office loses a
fortune it has been for many many years
the post office is too much business now
so now on top of it has this and the
amazons of the world and the others they
pay
very very little money they lose money
on every the post office loses money
which is ridiculous on every package it
delivers
but now on top of that and i'm not just
referring to amazon i'm talking about
all of the
competitors if there is such a thing to
amazon
there will be but if there is such a
thing but now on top of that
you'll have somebody like the governor
of nevada
come out with this massive plan out of
nowhere
to take millions of ballots and send
them all over state legislators
voted for it out of nowhere this is the
called the pros this is how states
decide stuff it's called federalism
just like many other places in west
virginia they indicted a
postman for doing something very bad you
know
and but there are many cases all over
the country whatever if you look
you'll be able to find there's a list of
them all over the country
and that has to do with universal
mail-in again
absentee is great same thing this year
like in florida they'll do absentee it's
talking about the same thing universal
mail-in ballots
is going to be a great embarrassment to
our country
well i have the right to do it we
haven't gotten there yet but we'll see
what happens
he doesn't have the right to do it suing
can't do a damn thing
and that's already been taken care of
we'll probably file something tomorrow
i do want to say that we're going to be
introducing a tremendous health care
plan so here we go
prior hopefully prior to the end of the
month it's just about completed now
in addition next month we'll be doing
the immigration plan
so we'll be doing that in september
we'll be doing after three and a half
years they're gonna do healthcare and
immigration in the next four weeks
and and i think that'll be before the
end of the month and i think it'll be
very impressive to a lot of people
thank you very much wow what a
completely unhinged event i mean just
everything about it checking the boxes
for cuckoo for cocoa puffs cuckoo for
cocoa puffs is the way that i like to
say it
absolutely nuts nothing for three and a
half years
in the next four weeks we will have a
new health care plan to replace
obamacare
and the immigration bill will be done
amazing efficiency isn't it
um i am going to be streaming in about a
half hour on twitch with hikaru nakamura
my next chess lesson top chess streamer
and top chess player
ladies and gentlemen if you are headed
out on youtube
please do me the favor of hitting that
subscribe button on the way out
there's 20 000 people watching on
youtube we are only
90 000 subscribers from a million help
us get to a million we can do it with
your help
and you'll be notified of future streams
so on your way out
hit that subscribe button make sure to
follow if you are watching on twitch the
the goal is 50 000 on twitch it's a more
modest goal than a million on youtube
but either way we love it um and i will
update you
as to the numbers over the very next
very short period of time as our
president likes to say and i'll be back
with you on twitch in about 30 minutes
for my chess lesson with the great
hikaru nakamura i will see you then
you